terror
on the streets of myanmar
a month after the military coup this
is now the norm
today it's tear gas being launched at
protesters
but on sunday some were again targeted
with live rounds
in mandalay a crowd tried to get a man
shot in the head to safety
medics treated a man with three bullet
wounds
this is deeply distressing but it's now
the reality of living in myanmar
those brave enough to stand up to the
military again today
know this battle may kill them
but they refused to give in even the
injured tell us
they'll return to the front line police
shot the
shot towards the road and you know the
people become very frightening
a lot of young people have been passed
away their life
the already month-long fear you could be
shot or
taken away at any moment has left people
terrified
[Music]
the leader many wanted is still detained
and today
facing new charges borders are closed
there is no escape
but she says they are her only
protection if military thugs
show up today the protesters
buried the dead among them a young
mother
but these coffins won't be the last
more blood will be spilt in myanmar
before this is over
siobhan robbins sky news